[Musique]
bien avant l'avènement de la médecine
moderne on utilisait les plantes pour se
soigner particulièrement chez les
peuples autochtones aujourd'hui
alchimiste veut s'inspirer de ce savoir
traditionnel pour développer de nouveaux
médicaments
[Musique]
puis toujours
la forêt
les plantes ont traditionnellement été
utilisés pour penser des blessures
soulager les symptômes de maladies et
soigner l'esprit notamment chez les
Premières Nations du Canada
en Saskatchewan une université veut
rapprocher le savoir traditionnel
autochtone et le savoir moderne des
scientifiques
[Musique]
l'Université des Premières Nations du
Canada qui a maintenant quatre campus à
travers la Saskatchewan est une
institution très unique
c'est une des seules institutions
dirigées par des Autochtones au Canada
elle existe depuis plus de 40 ans
le chimiste Benson zeful s'intéresse aux
propriétés médicinales des plantes qui
poussent dans sa province natale mais il
n'est pas autochtone
alors il se tourne vers ceux qui
détiennent ce savoir depuis des
générations
je voulais aider comme je peux partager
ce que je connais ainsi peut-être que
cela nous aidera à guérir et ce qui fait
quand l'université pourront utiliser ce
savoir avec sagesse
[Musique]
tous nos projets commencent par une
consultation des aînés avec qui nous
travaillons
[Musique]
nous leur demandons leur point de vue et
parfois ils partagent des informations
auxquelles nous ne nous attendions pas
des nombreuses années autochtones qui
enseignent son savoir traditionnel au
sein de l'université
c'est ce qui a incité Giulia du singbird
une étudiante en sciences d'ascendance
autochtones à choisir cette institution
elle assiste aujourd'hui 25 défaut dans
son laboratoire
une institution comme celle-ci qui
considère le savoir autochtone comme
faisant partie de la science occidentale
ainsi que ce que nos ancêtres
connaissaient avant la colonisation
pour apprendre ce savoir traditionnel
Vincenzo parcourt régulièrement la
saskatchoen afin d'y rencontrer des
années des quatre coins de la province
aujourd'hui il se rend à Prince Albert
pour la rencontre annuelle du Conseil
des années de l'université
[Musique]
c'est très important pour moi
d'avoir leur assistance à chaque fois
que c'est possible
[Musique]
je me souviens
que ma mère et ma grand-mère
utilisait toujours ses remèdes de la
Terre
nous n'avions nulle part où nous
procurer des médicaments
occidentaux
alors nos médicaments venaient de Mère
Nature
[Musique]
comme je viens de nier de guérisseur
cela était pratiqué sur la réserve où
j'y vais
nous avions toujours nous remède avec
nous si nous nous blessions dans la
forêt que l'on se faisait piquer par une
abeille on prenait une feuille d'arbre
on la mâchait on la posait sur la piqûre
et l'enflure disparaissait
les aînés apprennent aux chercheurs où
trouver ses plantes à quelle saison les
cueillir mais aussi comment les préparer
pour optimiser leur effet médicinal par
exemple dans certains cas les feuilles
sont infusées pour en faire des tisanes
alors que dans d'autres elles sont
plutôt utilisées sous forme d'ongan pour
soigner des problèmes de peau
certaines propriétés médicinales de
plantes utilisées par les Premières
nations sont connues depuis longtemps
par la science
par exemple le cornouiller stolonifère
contient une molécule la salicine à
partir de laquelle a été développée
l'acide acétylsalicylique l'ingrédient
actif de l'aspirine
l'aspirine vient du cornouiller
stallonifère
alors comme ma grand-mère l'utilisait
avec d'autres herbes c'était pour les
maux de tête les maux d'estomac tous les
problèmes du genre
une autre plante l'accord odorant a
démontré son efficacité contre certaines
bactéries comme eucoli
c'est notre remède incontournable
c'est un antibiotique
si quelqu'un est malade c'est la
première chose qu'on lui apporte mais ça
ne goûte pas bon
c'est ce que j'aime amené à mes enfants
et j'ajoutais un peu de miel et de jus
de citron
[Musique]
le chimiste rapporte ses connaissances
dans son laboratoire où il travaille à
isoler les molécules qui peuvent avoir
des propriétés médicinales intéressantes
il étudie plus particulièrement les
alcaloïdes des molécules dont la plante
se sert pour se défendre
[Musique]
des alcaloïdes amères qui font que les
plantes sont moins savoureuses pour leur
prédateurs
et il s'avère que ces alcaloïdes ont
aussi des propriétés médicinales
les travaux de 25 défaut et ses
collègues ont jusqu'à maintenant permis
de déterminer que la rallye à tige nue
le framboisier sauvage et le rosier des
prairies trois plantes médicinales
autochtones sont très riches en
polyphénols ces molécules ont des
propriétés antioxydantes qui
ralentissent la dégradation des cellules
et est ainsi à prévenir certaines
maladies
l'airby de l'université garde en mémoire
toutes les plantes recueillies au fil
des ans hélas plusieurs de ses plantes
sont en train de disparaître du paysage
de la Saskatchewan
plusieurs plantes autochtones sont plus
difficiles à trouver maintenant que nous
avons cultivé la terre nous avons
constaté cela en travaillant avec les
années cela nous indique aussi que
l'écosystème est menacé
mais grâce aux enseignements de leurs
aînés la jeune génération prend
conscience de l'importance de protéger
cet héritage
c'est important d'incorporer le savoir
autochtone dans les lois
environnementales actuelles
dans nos enseignements
la terre est sacrée et doit être protégé
pour notre avenir
les autochtones savent cela depuis des
millénaires
en reconnaissant la valeur de la science
autochtone les étudiants de l'université
des Premières nations apprennent aussi à
se reconnecter avec la culture de leurs
ancêtres c'est tellement important pour
eux
ils ont hâte de pouvoir avoir
ce bout de papier qui dit j'ai mon
diplôme de maîtrise
non pas du monde occidental mais d'ici
ils sont si fiers
ce projet est également une manière de
contribuer à la réconciliation entre le
Canada et les Premières nations
en tant que non autochtone qui pratique
la science je suis très conscient des
difficultés causées par les
colonisateurs
par les scientifiques qui ont extrait
des ressources d'une manière néfaste
quand je travaille avec ces communautés
avec les années je sais qu'ils en sont
conscients
cela mène parfois à des conversations
difficiles mais vraiment importantes
il est temps
nous avons fait beaucoup de chemin
c'est vrai nous sommes maintenant
capables de partager ce que nous savons
et ce que nous vivons
étaient relégués à l'arrière-plan
cela commence à sortir car nous avons
besoin de dire
mais aujourd'hui nous parlons nous
disons aux gens nous avons toujours été
ici